[Music]
you all watched the republican
convention last night just pretend
that's good uh
yeah
it helps if we're all on the same page
uh yeah big night yeah we finally got to
hear from mitt romney's wife ann she
spoke at the convention last night
people said she did a really good job i
thought she did a good job in her speech
at the republican convention just last
night and romney talked about meeting
mitt at a dance
that's true yeah apparently she leaned
over to her girlfriends and said who's
the guy over there with no rhythm
who's doing the robot
or as it's called then the mitt
he invented the robot did you know that
yeah yeah he was just walking to get a
cookie
[Music]
this is interesting during her speech
ann romney said after they got married
she and mitt lived in a basement
yeah it was a 42-room basement on the
french riviera
true
it's fantastic
[Applause]
would you like to see my basement
[Laughter]
i don't know why he does that
you know was the big event last night
chris christie gave the keynote address
yeah in his speech last night chris
christie said the word i 37 times romney
seven times and jobs only once
yeah
then there was the 622 times he said the
word ham
no word yet on what's that all about
hey it's rumored uh
i got it it's rumored that the
republican
give me a little message and i received
it
move it along uh
everyone's been wondering who's the
mystery speaker yeah they say there's
going to be a mystery speaker at the
convention well it's been rumored that
the republican convention mystery
speaker is going to be a hologram of
ronald reagan
i'm not lying that is
that's true yeah and the cool part is
he's going to perform a duet with tupac
[Applause]
[Music]
i finally got a chance to show off my
tattoos yeah
then romney's gonna come through and the
whole thing is gonna come together
magically
a lot of people talking about the
republican platform that's the big part
of the convention yeah the platform well
the new republican party platform calls
for a crackdown on porn
yeah
yeah the republicans say they'll start
the porn crackdown right after they
check out of their tampa hotels with
unlimited pay-per-view
do these things in order
now during the republican convention a
group of conservative gays threw a party
called
homocon
homocon yeah
people said it's just like comic-con but
less gay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look i i'm teddy roosevelt if he was a
jedi
uh what else going on well of course
things get turned over to the democrats
next week yeah democratic convention
yesterday
a medical marijuana group officially
endorsed barack obama for president
doesn't really help obama though because
they were just getting around to
endorsing him for 2008.
can't believe this story crazy story in
india
a man opened a clothing store named
hitler
claiming he didn't know who adolf hitler
was
yeah
to apologize he closed down the store
and opened up his new restaurant osama
bin rahman
[Applause]
inhaler uh
i'm the mom the mime who tells you what
he's doing
inhaler
this is an amazing story the oldest they
figured out who the oldest person on
facebook is the oldest person on
facebook is a 101 year old woman
101 years old on facebook yeah
she said i want to waste what little
time i have left
just yeah
[Music]
you